This is a very clear case of,
if this object didn't get help,
it would deteriorate even more over time.
I'm Sara, director of
conservation at Center Art Studio,
and today I'm going to walk you through
how we restore a polychrome
sculpture of St. Paul
from 1720.
The work that we're doing on St. Paul
is a full restoration.
This piece was very dirty.
It also was flaking,
so the paint was lifting and cupping.
It was actively in a state of degradation,
where any kind of transport
or touching or handling
of this piece would potentially risk
incurring additional damage.
This piece belongs to a private
collector in New York City.
We know that it's Latin colonial.
It is carved from a single piece of wood,
and it's been painted and gilded.
The book and the sword are
always symbolic of St. Paul,
so when you see those
attributes on a sculpture
or in a painting or work of art,
you can know that that saint
is meant to be St. Paul.
The writing on the book, it almost looks
like an early depiction
of music known as neumes.
That wouldn't be a typical attribute
of the book that St. Paul holds.
It stands out in this piece
as being a little bit unusual.
You never know exactly what conditions
something has been exposed to,
so there are certain climatic conditions
that can cause flaking.
We also know that because
the paint is flaking
in particular areas,
that means that the entire
sculpture is at risk.
The first step of this restoration
is to consolidate the flaking piece.
We can't clean the object
until it's stabilized.
Obviously, it's an
object that has history,
but it is nicely carved.
It had beautiful crackle lines,
and the colors were vibrant.
So if we remediate those issues,
we're going to end up with
a very beautiful object.
The book was heavily flaking.
It also is just a big
open horizontal plane
that's going to accumulate a lot of dirt.
We're going to do the
same consolidation process
to the feet.
So, the first thing we have
to do is apply this resin.
It's a completely stable
conservation-grade resin.
It's dissolved in a solvent.
We apply it with a brush,
and we apply it on the surface,
and also we try to get under the flakes
and into the cracks of the
sculpture as best we can.
Capillary action helps us here.
So this liquid flows under the chips
and into the recesses of the sculpture,
and the sculpture soaks it up.
That allows the flakes to become flexible,
and we can kind of push them
down back into position.
And then over the course of a few hours,
the solvent that that resin
was dissolved in evaporates,
but the resin remains.
And so that stabilizes the piece.
We use a solvent to
simultaneously remove that resin
and also clean the dirt off.
Just that one solvent
removes all those layers
and just gets us down to
the original paint layer.
There were felt pads on the bottom
of the base of the sculpture.
They also can be places
where dirt gets trapped.
So these were not really even necessary,
so we just removed them,
and we'll clean under those
areas and just start fresh.
Now that the piece has been cleaned,
we are going to move on
to filling the cracks
and areas of loss.
We use a water-based putty to fill in
any missing areas on the figure,
on the robe, on the base.
It goes on in sort of a
liquid, viscous state.
It basically is replacing
the missing gesso.
We overfill a little bit
because it is so easily
reversible and reducible
that you're going to get a more even fill
if you slightly overfill the area of loss.
You know, we put it on and
it looks a little wrong,
but then we can use water
to reduce these fills.
We also can use a very
fine-grit sandpaper.
You want to be very careful
that you're using a grit
that's not going to cause any damage
to the original painted surface.
Now that the sculpture has been filled,
we'll use brushes and conservation paints
to inpaint those fills and match,
as best we can, the original paint
that would have been in those places.
We use conservation paints
when we're doing inpainting.
And inpainting is simply
applying paint to fills.
This is different than overpainting,
which would be painting
over original surfaces.
It's really a process of color matching
to the surrounding area.
My approach when I'm doing it
is to typically do washes of color.
So I'll put a color on a fill,
and then I'll be like, OK,
this needs to simultaneously be
more red, green, yellow, and brown.
So then I'll add those colors to my brush,
and then I'll do it again.
So it's a series of washes that accumulate
to create the desired color.
It goes from looking like
a slightly broken object
in a state of repair to
looking like a complete object
quite quickly once all
the inpainting happens.
So that transition is
very satisfying to see.
All the areas were stabilized
and filled and color-matched correctly.
I think we did a very good job
in making it be a more complete object.
Now that we are done with the inpainting,
we apply shellac to the sculpture.
We apply it with a brush
all over the whole sculpture
and allow it to dry.
After the final coat is
applied to the sculpture,
we'll wipe it with a cloth, buff it,
and make sure that
there's no surface dust.
This restoration took a few
weeks for us to complete.
This piece needed to be conserved
because of the state of
degradation that it was in.
I'm very satisfied with this restoration.
A lot of time went into it.
I'm very happy with how the
whole project turned out.
And really, it's always very satisfying
to be able to not only stop damage
but prevent future damage
from happening on an object.
It just makes us feel
like we are helping extend the longevity
of a work of art through
the work that we do.